alex jones is uh calling us via zoom he
wants to clear things up about texas and
the snow conspiracy go ahead alex it's
good to speak with
crashing through the lies and
disinformation
it's alex jones infowars.com
good morning good morning now listen
clearly this is not fake snow my guys
tested it we know it's got the hexagonal
crystals 6 mpa compressive strength
antifa has been saying it's fake snow
because it is a reverse psycho-social
warfare
they want to discredit the proven fact
that the snow was put there
by bill gates with the weaponized
weather manipulation of the harp system
they tell texas keep your mouth shut
don't be a patriot it will freeze you
we're going to freeze you out this is in
state department memorandum 7277
read it infowars.com
i'm actually glad you're here today
because i couldn't figure out how the
people were saying the snow was fake
and the tie-in with bill gates but this
is what the cia does they do it through
antifa through q and on they say
it's a disinformation counter
intelligence operation look into
operation trust from the old soviet
union in the 1920s mainline
declassified it's the same as this they
discredit
real things the 5g big pharma takeover
the epstein science caught with bill
gates that's what
they want you to say anyone who
questions the weather is crazy
what you're saying is the snow is real
then they send out a fake story that the
snow was fake to make
your side look bad but actually the snow
is real
you can follow this yes why is
everything go back to bill gates
it is a first step towards weaponized
post global
post-human global takeover of the planet
they want to emerge in silicon
as a oh hold on one second howard we are
getting an exclusive
right now here on alex jones
exclusive howard you won't believe this
joining us now
is bill gates who says i'm right
it is i reptilian leader bill gates
i've come to sterilize christians and
destroy
humanity
[Music]
wow and just like i said gates you're on
a throne of needles almost like
game of thrones yes it's my throne of
death
excuse me gates hasn't gotten good sleep
in days
well gates if you want good sleep for a
good price you need
x2 ultra sleep that's right it's an
ancient recipe of aspirin and dish soap
full of vitamin o this will knock you
out cold take one pill you'll sleep for
10 days
actually matter of fact i can use a good
shoes right now hold on i'm going to
take one rider
it is so good half off while supplies
last
so good infowars
[Laughter]
you know alex during uh a wake up alex
just one
one more question during the commercial
infowars
all right answer one last question who
is worse bill gates
or george soros i would say gates
works for soros gates is a newer version
of soros so soros is the prime
controller he is the grace
he is the chacom agent who has seen the
subversion
paradigm manipulation of all this but
you cannot discredit the fact
that bill gates ordered sixty thousand
dollars worth of hot dogs to his hotel
room which believe me if you know
anything about that and podesta hillary
obama
sixty thousand dollars worth of hot dogs
is not what you think it's children he's
eating children i never heard that one
before but i remember
uh years ago you were promoting the fact
that shrimp were turning gay
and and so this is a whole new level uh
you know what i mean absolutely shrimp
salmon and the frogs were all turned gay
because that's what they want to do they
want to sterilize
the population that's how you get to the
post human end game that's what
the same satanists want to cut off our
arms and legs
listen i got a packed out show today we
got a lot we got a lot of info warrior
feedback to get to and we have
reptilian tom hanks calling in you know
him from
castaway and running the reptilian
hollywood pedophile call so i'll be
talking to him later
stay tuned infowars.com
[Music]
infowars.com